le monde dont je rêve sera un monde où
les humains sont tous égaux un monde où
le réchauffement climatique serait
enrayé et même inversé un monde où les
humains seraient capables de produire la
sphère de Dyson pour résumer c'est une
mégastructure hypothétique qui permet en
entourant le soleil sans cacher la
lumière de produire une énergie
illimitée sans polluer
pour de tels projets tous les pays
doivent être unis donc pas de guerre des
personnes comme Poutine nous en empêche
mon monde idéal serait vraiment dans
tous les humains serait égaux il n'y
aurait pas de discrimination de racisme
de sexisme ou d'homophobie
ils seront tous libres de leurs actes
sans personne pour les juger sur leur
façon de penser d'agir ou sur leur
physique durant leur scolarité de si
c'est le 18 ans les apprendront les
bases lire et écrire compter et
découvriront des métiers en primaire
puis se formeront au métier qu'ils ont
choisi dès le collège
ce serait aussi un monde dans lequel il
n'y aurait plus de pollution donc plus
de réchauffement climatique et les
plantes les animaux et la biodiversité
serait très abondants
le manque parfait dans laquelle je
voudrais vivre et le nôtre avec moins de
défauts comme la pollution et les
différents types de discrimination et
sinon je voudrais juste m'amuser sans me
demander quel métier faire plus tard
bref voilà le monde dans lequel je
voudrais vivre
maman utopique s'arrête un monde dans
lequel il n'y aurait ni de guerre ni
dictateur ou d'épidémie
ce sera un monde qui ne serait pas
recouvert de ville et l'immeuble où le
vert et le bleu remplacerait le gris
triste et sale
il y aurait plein de petites maisons
avec des jardins il y aurait de grandes
forêts des lacs il y aurait des mers et
des Océans propres et la faune et la
fleur aurait encore toutes leurs places
il n'y aura pas d'espèces de plantes et
d'animaux qui disparaîtraient l'habitat
et la nourriture Charles est disponible
pour tous
j'aimerais vivre dans un monde où on
peut assumer nos différences où on ne
doit pas devoir ressembler à tout le
monde pour pouvoir être accepté dans la
société
un monde où la gentillesse est banalisée
en monde sans hiérarchie 100 personnes
qu'on doit plus respecter que d'autres
j'aimerais vivre dans un monde où la
moquerie n'est pas quelque chose de
drôle et d'amusant à faire
un monde où on respecte la planète les
autres et surtout soi-même
Lilou Riwan Mohamed colline Maëlle ils
sont nés en 2008 ils vivent à Rennes et
sont dans le même collège nous les
suivons dans leur vie sur une décennie
depuis leur année de 6e avec une idée en
tête quel avenir les attend qui
seront-ils en 2030
les réponses se dessinent avec le temps
à travers cette série documentaire qu'il
est impossible d'écrire à l'avance voici
quelques moments de vie capturés dans
l'année celle de leur 13 ans
cette année nos 5 jeunes comptent parmi
les grands du collège ils sont en 4e
excellent
la note maximale
l'orthographe ce serait quand même bien
d'y prendre garde les noms propres
prénoms des majuscules les connaissances
c'est bien
le génie du père de famille blancsetre
de la famille je vous rappelle que les
hommes sont prédominants et les femmes
comptent pour du beurre ici voilà quel
est le nom du dieu des Enfers oui Maëlle
et non pas voilà quelle déesse s'oppose
à la mission des nez alors Riwan est-ce
que vous vous rappelez
qui a été choisie
Aphrodite que promet chacune d'elles à
Paris alors oui à moi Madame
promet le plus beau des royaumes
athéna lui promet de le rendre à massive
le combat et Aphrodite le premier à la
main de la plus belle femme du monde
excellent je vous félicite donc je vous
retrouve mardi
en cours de techno Lilou Riwan et
Mohamed voit l'envers du décor allez
vous installez rapidement vous allez
attaquer directement le travail sur le
labyrinthe il passe de joueur à créateur
de jeux vidéo
l'histoire du jeu donc avec écran
d'accueil règle du jeu
maniement du jeu d'accord bon ça va
c'est facile
une fois tu retournes au début si tu
récupères l'objet tu gagnes le truc
c'est écrit gagner tu passes au niveau
suivant
donc on va dire que c'est ça bam il
arrive il va Miss retire et là ce que je
peux commencer
première écran d'accueil et puis vous
allez choisir un nom pour le jeu
non
l'aventurier le labyrinthe le laby
rencontre
le chemin de l'enfer
le prof de techno est aussi le prof
principal
vos camarades délégués
à tout moment il peut lancer un échange
sur la vie de classe
j'aime pas trop l'ambiance
puissent répondre quelle est la critique
qu'est-ce qu'il fait que vous trouvez
que l'ambiance est pas top
mais en fait ça dépend de des personnes
et surtout ça dépend bah de
je sais pas trop comment développer ça
mais c'est un peu compliqué à en parler
maintenant mais c'est voilà mais ça
reste quand même en grande partie
compliquée
ok je vous souhaite une bonne journée
bisous
c'est particulièrement en sport et en
arts plastiques oui en fait c'est
des fois elle se moque de moi
pression sur le physique ou soit sur sur
juste elle rigole en parlant de mon
style vestimentaire etc d'accord et ben
rumeurs ou soit elle rigole genre en me
regardant mal etc et donc c'est pas
hyper son plastique c'est souvent c'est
dur depuis un moment ça dure depuis à
peu près le début de l'année enfin vers
le oui
d'accord faut pas hésiter tu sais Lilou
quelqu'un d'autre tant que ok
est-ce que tu veux que je les rencontre
ces jeunes filles
on peut pas laisser continuer ça comme
ça
oui mais dans tes yeux là c'est ça c'est
pas une situation que tu oui
de leur créer de problèmes etc parce que
si
elle te crée des problèmes d'accord donc
c'est pas une histoire de leur créer de
problèmes si l'histoire tu dois venir au
collège en étant sereine et pas en
craignant de te faire moquer par tes
camarades donc il faut qu'on mette ça en
place absolument
j'ai rencontré quand même je pense
comme ça
il faut qu'on trouve une petite solution
tout le monde doit être bien donc il y a
pas de raison
donc je vais les rencontrer d'accord
allez bonne journée
oui bonjour Alors je tenais à vous
appeler parce que j'ai eu une petite
discussion avec Lilou aujourd'hui il y a
quelques camarades qui se moqueraient un
peu d'elle de temps en temps
qu'elle ne remonte en tout cas je l'ai
vraiment vu atteinte tout à l'heure
qu'elle a eu très vite les larmes aux
yeux
vous avez utilisé le bonbon on est
proche du harcèlement au bout d'un
moment
un peu par ses camarades voilà donc
peut-être avec la Provence je sais quoi
elle voulait interdit d'en parler au
collège quoi vu l'état émotionnel dans
lequel je l'ai trouvé je pense que il
faut que ça cesse immédiatement
donc voilà moi ma demande aujourd'hui
c'était que vous puissiez en parler un
petit peu avec elle
expérimenter encore un peu
cette année Maëlle s'est sérieusement
mis aux échecs
c'est même inscrit dans un club
bonjour
cette année ça fait réfléchir
en plein de
truc à apprendre
à faire
tout un petit monde
sur un échiquier
sinon Maëlle dévore toujours des romans
et des gros il lit même des pièces de
théâtre et dans tout ça il trouve le
temps de continuer le piano
et en plus il s'intéresse à l'élection
présidentielle 2022 d'ailleurs une
proposition de réforme l'interpelle
tout prof doit être
remplacé par un de ses collègues il est
absent
tu vas remplacer un autre
très bien compris
à la maison chacun a sa façon de
s'informer les journaux télévisés la
radio ou les réseaux sociaux
a-t-elle trop de pouvoir
la France doit-elle rester dans l'OTAN
et ça donne des envies de faire un point
sur ce qu'ils savent de l'élection
présidentielle
demander pour qui je vois c'est ça
qui tu connais à peu près tous les
candidats la gauche elle est
complètement disloquée la politique
c'est vraiment pas un truc qui
m'intéresse il y a beaucoup de temps
candidats
Emmanuel Macron alors je crois si droite
non si je me trompe j'ai pas envie de me
tromper c'est cendres non peut-être un
peu sur la droite une droite quoi pas
non plus extrême quoi c'est droite non
c'est gauche c'est les deux centre c'est
un centre
Jean-Luc Mélenchon c'est à gauche
partout
à droite
Eric Zemmour qui est de droite droite
extrême droite je sais pas c'est extrême
droite Marine Le Pen qui à droite
extrême droite
qui d'autre encore il y a pas la
mère de Paris
qui d'autre qui d'autre j'ai plus trop
de nom en tête il y a Poutou je pense
qu'il est de droite je dirais gauche
mais je connais pas il y a un mec qui
s'appelle Rousseau Roussel
il est communiste
je dirais droite
du pain et
qui fait penser à gauche je pense non et
les droites il en reste un
jean Lassalle voilà je cherchais son nom
dans la vie il y a un avant et un après
la quatrième notamment parce que c'est
l'année où sont abordés les sujets un
peu plus pour adultes donc nous
aujourd'hui on va travailler sur ce
qu'on appelle la vie sexuelle et
affective alors je vous présente le
premier jeu c'est le jeu du Pili-Pili
alors je sais pas ce que vous savez ce
que c'est le Pili-Pili mais c'est
globalement quelque chose d'un peu
pimenté si vous n'avez pas envie de
répondre parce que vous êtes gêné par
une question vous avez le droit de ne
pas la faire d'accord il m'a innocente
ferme les yeux
la moyenne de la taille du sexe d'un
homme en érection en France entre 18 et
20 cm donc c'est la réponse A B entre 12
et 13 cm
lacet entre 15 et 16 cm la d autre
réponse
tu hésites
alors c'est très très disparate dans la
classe là alors même si les statistiques
c'est un peu toujours ici on est plutôt
entre 15 et 16 cm donc la moyenne donc
c'est la réponse c'est vous êtes
plusieurs à l'avoir surestimé ici vous
êtes passé à 18 18 20 cm alors si on
n'est pas dans la moyenne c'est pas on
n'est pas normal d'accord parce que il
peut y en avoir plus petit pour avoir
des plus grands ça reste une moyenne
vous savez ce que c'est une moyenne on
estime que à cause de la pornographie on
se retrouve avec des idées reçues sur
par exemple la taille du sexe les
relations sexuelles les actes sexuels
etc qui sont comment dire faussés par la
vision de ce qui n'est que du cinéma
d'accord une autre carte la jalousie
c'est bon pour le couple point
d'interrogation donc est-ce que la
jalousie à sa place dans une relation
qu'elle soit amicale ou une relation
amoureuse
alors j'en vois beaucoup qui osent la
tête l'italien pour moi la jalousie
c'est ça montre que on aime la personne
mais de toute façon on contrôle pas du
coup nos sentiments font contre pas nos
émotions donc on peut enfin c'est pas de
notre faute c'est normal d'être jaloux
parce que c'est normal d'être jaloux
c'est obligatoire d'être d'avoir une
relation non non qui sont pas d'accord
avec toi Lucile moi je pense que si on
aime quelqu'un déjà on veut son bonheur
d'accord donc enfin si genre je sors
avec quelqu'un et que il a plein
d'amitié bah d'accord c'est sa vie je
lui fais confiance à partir du moment où
quand tu juges tu touches ton téléphone
il commence à bégayer enfin c'est
bizarre mais je trouve qu'elle jaloux
c'est un peu genre contrôler sa vie
genre dire bah non tu fais pas si tu
fais pas ça mais ça se fait pas de faire
cela c'est elle va faire qu'on va c'est
vraiment la vie de quelqu'un possessif
vous avez l'air quand même un peu mitigé
quand même un peu sceptique mais là
quand on a eu une personne on lui fait
confiance alors que là
je suis en mai oui c'est un c'est vrai
que si on est jaloux ça veut dire que on
aime vraiment la personne mais c'est un
peu bizarre parce que on lui fait pas
confiance on lui fait pas confiance donc
c'est important la confiance on écoute
apprendre à maîtriser ses émotions c'est
quelque chose qui se travaille donc ça
peut faire mal ça peut être difficile
mais je pense que c'est quelque chose
qui doit aussi être un travail sur soi
bon c'était intéressant
ludique ça c'est intéressant la ludique
par le jeu ça permet de libérer la
parole et d'apprendre des choses aussi
bon allez je vous libère
libérer la parole peut être mais les
verrous des garçons n'ont pas
complètement sauté
vous pensez pas qu'il faudrait
pour l'instant
bonjour comment allez-vous
nos collectifs qui travaillent sur les
questions de d'égalité fille garçon donc
je vais vous inviter à aller vous
positionner de ce côté-là de la pièce
en ligne on va vous donner des cartes de
personnages il y a quelques traits de
caractère dessus donc à partir du moment
où vous avez une carte dans les mains
vous êtes ce personnage et dans le jeu
vous allez essayer de vous imprégner et
d'imaginer que vous êtes pour de vrai
cette personne là si vous pensez pouvoir
répondre oui alors vous faites un pas en
avant les phrases qu'on va vous donner
ont tout un lien avec le consentement ou
avec la relation aux autres ok alors
première affirmation j'ai beaucoup
d'amis si vous pensez que votre
personnage que vous incarnez a beaucoup
d'amis nous avancez d'un pas
je suis actif sur les réseaux sociaux
je n'ai jamais été l'objet de rumeurs
début 6e je suis vraiment rendue compte
que les beaucoup de filles qui ont lancé
beaucoup beaucoup de rumeurs et à quoi
ça sert elles ont qu'à regarder les
Anges de la téléréalité et se taire pas
faire la même chose dans la vraie vie je
n'ai jamais eu peur de venir le matin au
collège
mais du coup ça pouvait vraiment glisser
en fait c'est ça le problème c'est pas
c'est amusant que pour elle en fait
je n'ai jamais été gêné dans les
vestiaires
je n'ai jamais subi de moquerie
je ne me suis jamais moquée de personnes
pour faire comme les autres
on a toujours respecté mes décisions mes
choix
merci restez sur place et regardez où
vous êtes les uns les autres
observez-vous un peu ouais
est-ce qu'il y a des phrases qui vous
ont un peu plus surprises choquées vous
êtes dit mais qu'est-ce que ça fait là
par exemple je n'ai jamais subi de
moqueries mais il y a des personnes qui
ont avancé alors que de toute manière
presque tout le monde subit des
moqueries et c'est pas forcément à cause
de certains critères que c'est mon point
de vue mais que certains critères et je
me suis dit mais tout le monde subit des
moqueries donc je comprends pas pourquoi
peu importe le de toute façon quelqu'un
qui veut se moquer il choisit n'importe
quel prétexte donc
j'ai toujours subi des mots clés en fait
genre je stresse beaucoup de mon
physique de comment je comment je me
comporte comment j'ai vraiment j'arrive
vraiment c'est vraiment compliqué pour
moi d'être vraiment moi-même dans un
lieu où tu es moqué pour absolument tout
ce que tu fais quand tu es trop
superficiel quand tu es trop naturel les
mots cris il faut essayer de parler
croire mais quand on te dit quelque
chose de pas sympa tu vas avoir le
réflexe de les croire et de te remettre
en question au lieu de simplement dire
c'est pas à moi de me remettre en
question c'est à toi et tu vas pas
vraiment changer les gens donc c'est ce
qu'il faut essayer de laisser glisser
mais ça c'est quelque chose que je
travaille encore dessus laisser glisser
les insultes et c'est glisser les
moqueries c'est pas parce que tu as
insulté qu'on t'a mal parlé que il faut
tout d'un coup se mettre que sans faire
ma toilette et pleurer comme jamais
enfin c'est vraiment des des fausses
croyances en fait
nous sommes en décembre
Lilou attend son bulletin de notes
donc là de premier trimestre de
4e
attention ici les élèves sont notés sur
4 et pas sur 20 alors le bulletin de
Lilou
que je vous laisse découvrir
mathématique tu t'accroches alors là tu
vois les maths c'est la petite remarque
moins positive Lilou semble souvent
ailleurs
mais ça m'ennuie
bonsoir
alors comment ça se passait
dans toutes les matières ou ça va il y a
des matières qui te demandent vraiment
vraiment du travail
le français faut que je travaille
l'orthographe
mais sinon ça va bon le bulletin du coup
on a du très bon on n'est pas loin du
très très bon avec un petit deux qui
traîne mais avec voilà un des efforts de
feu des efforts de noter et globalement
on a
un riboine qui travaille qui fait des
efforts faudrait apparemment quand même
un petit peu plus de participation orale
puisque tu en penses je suis d'accord
comment ça s'est passé ce premier
trimestre
voilà je peux plus de commentaires
globalement c'est effectivement si une
classe qui est ressentie comme ça
fatigue dynamique travailleuse
et ça c'est le butin moi
c'est un bon bulletin avec un petit
bémol on est tous d'accord pour dire que
bonne capacités
et que il pourrait certainement faire un
petit peu plus que ce qui fait déjà
ça nous suffit pas il faut que tu en
fasses plus encore je me rappelle depuis
l'école primaire c'est toujours ça mon
mec peut faire plus il peut il est
capable de faire plus c'est toujours de
cette année
il alterne les phases de je suis à fond
dans le travail je fais les choses etc
et puis par moment
je suis à fond dans la discussion et il
aime bien rigoler il est très dynamique
il a besoin de bouger etc etc donc et
puis ben voilà c'est ce qu'on te
reproche c'est le manque de
concentration
je vous laisse le temps d'avoir plus de
difficultés peut-être l'année 4ème c'est
plus compliqué je pense que ça vient des
cours que ça donne toi
concentration contrairement aux autres
années je sais pas
du coup ouais c'est quand même faire des
efforts mais des fois c'est ta pas envie
tu as envie de te faire autre chose etc
quoi
toutes tes belles capacités que tu
montres en EPS en histoire en français
etc il faut le généraliser et puis être
préparé une super belle année de
troisième
Quentin qui t'ouvre toutes les portes et
ben du coup tu peux choisir quelle porte
tu vas ouvrir pour ta formation que ce
soit en lycée général Alice et
technologique en lycée de professionnel
donc là tu ouvres les portes un petit
peu
pour aller là où tu as envie d'aller
merci beaucoup c'est moi qui vous
remercie
bonne soirée au revoir
c'est une petite pause pour ce préparer
à plus travailler ensuite
non parce que on soit on dirait pas
comme ça mais attends je dois aller à
l'école pendant 20 ans après tout c'est
20 ans je vais devoir faire des si
possible des grandes écoles des choses
comme ça pour trouver un métier puis
après je vais devoir travailler jusqu'à
bon on va dire 60 60 j'ai oublié c'est
quel âge la retraite je crois il va y
avoir une réforme pour les 65 ans mais
sinon après j'ai oublié bref on va dire
60 ans et après enfin à ce moment là je
pourrais me reposer du coup
ce petit moment de ces petites pauses
je me dis ah non mais j'aurais dû faire
une pause en quatrième je le savais
c'est pas très très propre
de Paris
personnes
Notre-Dame depuis l'incendie
c'est tellement grand franchement ça
vaut plus noté
parce que moi en fait ça m'intéresse pas
trop les
loups est passionné d'histoire et en
venant au Panthéon elle avait une idée
en tête moi je vais enfin faire
en fait c'est ça le cri
c'est ça
le tombeau de Rousseau
il est là
c'est André Malraux qui était ministre
de la Culture
hommage
de France des femmes et des hommes de
toute origine et de toute condition ont
sauvé des Juifs des persécutions
antisémites et des camps d'extermination
et toi ça c'est vachement important quoi
parce qu'en fait en France il y a tous
ces gens qui anonyme qui pour quelque
chose des petits actes en fait comment
mon grand-père ils étaient dans une
ferme à l'extérieur de reine ils ont ils
ont hébergé des compagnies juives pour
les cacher moi et mon nom j'avais parlé
comme quelque chose de d'héroïque quoi
c'était tout à fait normal quoi
il a dit j'ai décidé d'être heureux
faire cette bon pour ma santé
mais aussi était avec une femme des
lumières Émilie du Châtelet elle est là
traduit en deux langues en italien et en
français en texte je sais plus quoi
c'était sa femme non en fait elle était
déjà mariée
allez on va ressortir
à la gloire dégénéraux
a une dent contre Napoléon Bonaparte
c'est qu'elle a quelques bases
historiques
donc souvenez-vous on essaye de
comprendre en quoi les guerres
napoléoniennes et les conquêtes de la
France vont influencer les autres pays
d'Europe ou pas c'est ce qu'on essaye de
comprendre la Révolution française elle
arrive dans ces pays les
révolutionnaires d'abord puis les armées
napoléoniennes en apportant avec eux la
Déclaration des Droits de l'Homme
comment les populations par exemple en
Espagne dans la partie Est de l'Europe
vont réagir griwan donnez-moi des
exemples
dans le texte du document 2 il est écrit
en octobre
1792 les soldes d'un Français occupent
Mayence en rhénani les habitants les
accueillent avec joie et fondent dans le
club de Jacobins donc on danse on chante
on plante des arbres quelle va devenir
latitude des populations de ces pays-là
et pourquoi les choses vont changer
Lilou
réagissent de manière qu'on la France
les libère libère leur pays qui vont
avoir plus de droits
comme des envahisseurs c'est carrément
l'inverse oui Mohamed
ou les Français arrivent comme des
libérateurs et le moment où il est
considère comme des envahisseurs il se
passait combien de temps ça dépend des
endroits quelques mois voilà
et on verra ça un peu plus tard quoi de
mieux que l'histoire pour se faire une
culture politique et vous avez le
document page 83 d'ailleurs lors de
l'élection présidentielle nos cinq
jeunes ont été marqués par une
proposition très médiatisée celle
d'obliger les gens à donner un prénom
dit français à leurs enfants c'est
souvent comme ça dans l'histoire je
comprends pas où est la logique en fait
dans cette phrase quoi genre
c'est pas parce que tu donnes un prénom
de n'importe qui n'est pas français à un
de tes enfants je combat en quoi ça
exclu de la société française pour moi
ça veut rien dire
on a tous des prénoms qui viennent pas
forcément
traditionnellement de la France
Elliott Adam Nassim moi-même en soi il a
raison de dire que c'est pas un nom
traditionnel français mais c'est pas
mais pour moi c'est pas une raison pour
vouloir le changer quoi c'est ça qui
fait la beauté de la France j'ai eu la
chance d'avoir toujours eu des copains
qui m'ont jamais critiqué pour ça ni
rien quoi nous apporte de la culture et
plein de choses en fait ça reflète notre
d'où on vient nos origines
c'est important la France est telle
qu'elle est aujourd'hui faut pas la
renvoyer dans un passé je pensais que la
pensée des gens savaient un peu évolué
depuis
avant en fait pour d'autres personnes je
comprends que ce soit pas normal
peut-être que eux elles étaient
habituées à avoir différents types de
prénoms français et que du jour au
lendemain ça commettre ça commençait à
être mixte qui est plein d'autres trucs
et tout et du coup ça a commencé à
déstabiliser les choses pour eux pour
ces personnes là du coup ça je danse de
ce point de vue là je pourrais
comprendre quoi
dans le dos ce soir les esprits sont
légers
pour les 14 ans de colline les garçons
mettent la main à la pâte
et ils sont sous le contrôle avisé de la
maîtresse des lieux
on dirait pas
mais derrière ces air de patronne Coline
cache un mal-être qu'elle n'avait encore
jamais dévoilé
je vous montre pas ce que je ressens
parce que les autres pourraient me juger
donc du coup je le montre pas
j'aime pas trop le faire remarquer j'ai
plutôt tendance à m'effacer il y a
plutôt des choses je me dis ouais non ne
le fais pas ou alors cache-toi
j'aimerais être invisible genre mais
complètement invisible
genre personne ne me voit
ce serait bien
non moi je veux plein de bougies
par les gens en fait j'ai peur de ce
qu'ils peuvent penser de MOI pourtant
quand tu es avec tes amis franchement ça
a l'air d'aller en fait je suis
différente avec les gens que avec moi
même
mais les gens qui sont quand même de moi
genre mes amis
si jamais j'enlève cette espèce de
carapace en fait
ben je sais pas ce qu'ils pensent soin
de moi du coup je le fais pas
mais les amis
ça fait pour t'aimer ce que tu es
ouais mais des fois c'est pas moi
mais du coup il t'aime toi oui
j'arrive à être moi
mais c'est pas la majorité du temps
mais tu penses que c'était 100 %
toi-même avec eux tu ferais le tri entre
les amis
ouais mais non j'ai pas envie
bonne soirée
le mois de moi quand je suis dans ma
chambre il est complètement différent du
mois à l'extérieur de la maison
il y a des choses que je laisse dans ma
chambre quand je vois par exemple que
j'essaie de cacher
c'est pas tellement j'assume pas mais
en fait j'ai toujours je pense
eu deux personnalités un petit peu
différentes j'ai appris à
garder ma personnalité à moi pour moi et
à montrer ce que je voulais montrer aux
autres
il y en a avec qui tu enlèves ce visage
là
non
j'écoute du Adèle pink
de jacket Billie eilish mais
principalement Taylor Swift je les ai
tous en fait
et du coup mon préféré c'est celui-là il
est un peu même habillé
tout le temps
en ce moment c'est une deux trois quatre
cinq six sept huit neuf
elle la Disiz
c'est vraiment ça me remonte vraiment le
moral des coups de cette chanson là
c'est surtout beaucoup de paroles à un
moment qui me marque énormément et en
fait ce qui se passe ça fait penser à
moi
potentiel c'est un peu oui ils m'ont dit
que que en fait tout venait de moi en
fait et que j'ai commencé à perdre tout
mon potentiel parce que les personnes
ils me reproche à des choses et que je
me suis mis à faire tout pour les gens
et que et qu'en fait j'ai tout tout mon
potentiel s'est mis à se perdre en fait
ça parle du fait qu'on a du mal à faire
confiance aux gens et quand on est un
peu brisé on essaie de
continuer à essayer en fait
au moins on essaie et on essaie de faire
au mieux pour moi c'est vraiment une
musique qui me représente une certaine
manière parce que parce qu'en fait tous
les jours j'essaie
pour Mohamed
test là la musique est un peu moins
introspective
maman ne laissait pas mignon et niska
à moi
ils vont voir ce qu'on regarde
ok on en fait un autre vas-y
plus facile en vrai
le temps passe
nous arrivons en dernier trimestre de
l'année et Riwan a quelques lauriers a
récolter avec un immense plaisir que je
souhaite à tous la bienvenue au collège
les Gayeulles pour les remises des prix
au gagnant du concours ArelA 2022 le
sujet du concours 2022 était des dieux
et des hommes quand les dieux s'emmêlent
550 inscrits dans l'académie de Rennes
bravo 55 lauréat et c'est une élève de
4e qui a donc le premier prix
alors une enceinte connectée
félicitation le deuxième
rewin warer
élève de Claire rouget hurquin
qui pourra pour finir sa culture avec
Astérix chez les pistes
donc félicitations à tous et lauréats à
tout et professeur qui ont un summener
leurs élèves à la réussite
je vous remercie d'être venu
pour les Percy Jackson c'est bon
on peut dire que ça fait tout
c'est du même auteur
dans celui-là on retrouve Percy Jackson
qui est grec qui arrive dans un clan
romain j'adore la lecture
si vous avez vu les adaptations aussi au
cinéma les films résument trop les
livres trop condensés pour vous pour les
connaisseurs bah voilà une perspective
vous allez passer au lycée Châteaubriand
dans 2 ans vous allez faire l'option au
cinéma audiovisuel et dans quelques
années vous nous montez et vous nous
remontez les parties
on est fier de vous
il était drôle
justement Châteaubriant
c'est le lycée tout près du collège et
très prisé des bons élèves
elle a dit voilà on a les capacités de
d'aller chercher du travail en plus pour
combler nos manques pour se préparer au
lycée quoi au collège on nous apprend
pas à bosser on travaille pas attention
le lycée Chateaubriand c'est là que
s'imagine Maëlle et ses copains
ils ont décroché en seconde trop niveau
ouais ça c'est sûr
géographie géopolitique et sciences
politiques
parce que
il en avait trois cette année c'est
toujours à 18h sauf le vendredi vaut
mieux prendre des options pour
s'habituer à bosser
tous les cas faut après pour le
parcoursup
pour la mère de Mohamed avant le lycée
il y a déjà la troisième et son fameux
stage en entreprise
elle veut lancer les recherches dès
maintenant
alors
vous développez web
chargé de CRM ingénieur de cybersécurité
pour ordinateur en gros développeur
informatique développeur mobile un point
des applications
je sais pas exactement ce que c'est bah
voilà quoi
mais
je réfléchis sur ce que tu veux faire je
sais mais voilà tu es encore
moi je viens et faire au moins pour
essayer mais ça emballe pas tant que ça
non plus
moi ça m'inquiète parce que voilà il
faut
il faut trouver quelque chose pour le
stage et d'où tu es venu l'idée de faire
de faire pour moi un métier dans
l'informatique
jusqu'à la première fois que tu me dis
ça je m'y attendais pas du tout oui mais
tu passes que tu sais pas encore quoi
faire bah je me dis bah tu peux tenter
ça et puis voilà tu verras
l'année scolaire est terminée
Lilou fait le bilan ces problèmes ne se
sont pas arrangés la quatrième a été
rude alors elle a pris une décision
l'année prochaine je vais changer de
collège je quitte les gayeuls et je vais
dans le collège dans le collège privé
juste derrière l'ascension c'est une
décision que j'ai pris j'espère me faire
de nouveaux amis pouvoir être dans une
classe sans se sentir jugé constamment
en fait
cette année ça a été très compliqué je
me suis pas sentie à ma place dans
l'établissement mais en fait le problème
je pense que il vient aussi de moi et
que bah en fait on peut pas enfin on
peut pas on peut pas changer non plus le
comment comment les élèves de la classe
réagissent comment comment
l'établissement devrait devrait gérer
l'établissement en fait je peux pas
changer ça en fait
j'ai énormément de mauvais souvenir au
gayeul et que je me sentais pas bien
dans la classe c'est pour ça que que
j'ai envie de reprendre un peu à zéro
une certaine manière
je suis contente de d'aller de l'avant
de pouvoir aller dans un complètement
autre environnement mais je serais un
peu triste quand même de quitter mais
bon je pense que c'est pour le mieux
enfin j'espère que c'est pour le mieux
mais voilà
au rayon des changements radicaux
colline a aussi quelque chose à annoncer
je m'en vais
je pars en Angleterre pendant un an
ses parents ont décidé de partir en
famille à Manchester avec des objectifs
pour les enfants apprendre à s'adapter
et à parler anglais en immersion
et le tabouret et c'est tout
non je l'emmène
je vais être dans une école anglaise
avec des Anglais
au début ça va être un peu galère parce
que je parle pas anglais couramment
moi je comprends pas
un mot sur 10
j'ai fini ma chambre
je sais pas où je mets les trucs
bah oui
il faut vider tous les placards de cette
cuisine
tu peux faire ça aussi je suis là
d'abord
c'est très bien
il y a pas besoin de respirer
et ben ça va aller là
je voulais la voir avec moi devant
pour voyage
là je pars dans une demi-heure
je suis même pas en train de réaliser
que je vais partir et que je serai pas
là pendant un an
Ushi à Ouistreham
1 2 1 3